is going on with this logo two people on
a typewriter this typewriter somehow
function like a Jaeger some it must be a
pretty sad world where magic debunker is
an actual thing you can get famous doing
someone who takes the fun out of every
damn thing it's almost like getting
famous for being a Santa Claus isn't
real informer and cinemasins
this asshole kid has to run through a
whole crowd to go see his dad
rather than already being on the stage
with him watching like a child that is
loved movie suggests magic debunk or
Morgan Freeman that's literally the only
reporter on the scene and it's being
filmed by multiple news stations despite
being a magic debunker and not a
reporter yeah I never sent Josh a Morgan
Freeman has been tasked to narrate a
great many movies span I'm sorry this
movie ain't Shawshank also this whole
beginning part is a rehash of the first
movie in case you walked into a movie
called now you see me to thinking the
two was a cute way of saying also I feel
it's reasonable for me to ask how this
asshole in prison got in cell private
access to a laptop connected to the
Internet
are you listening horseman having just
written sins for x-men apocalypse prior
to this movie this line is a little too
on the nose
this is games and it's not working for
me
odd wording choices aside this guy's
right and he's waited a year to voice
this displeasure to the magical gods who
somehow actually exist wait this mother
who is king of all the magic fuckers
last movie has gone on pretending to be
an FBI agent for an entire year after
the last movies events Cowen I know I'm
new here but as far as I can tell people
who don't even know you think you're an
asshole
who says this type of when they're new
at a job when you're two people at the
same time one of them is bound to trip
the other and when that happens I will
be there so this guy's own - Ruffalo see
how he got away with the last movies
bullshit scot-free is this just for
dramatic comedic tension because it
obviously is I recognize you you did
that you did that be grave geek magic
thing didn't you we find out later this
trip was performed eight years ago and
somehow Daniel remembers this person
even if she looks like Lizzy Caplan over
here these movies in a nutshell people
I'm so sorry that Henley left you you
know what I heard that isla Fisher
didn't want to be in a second one of
these movies oh she was pregnant at the
time well how convenient
gonna happen huh you're gonna stay here
dude you've already seen her get into
your apartment set up a Rube Goldberg
fake death appear out of nowhere get out
of your first attempt to tie her up and
now you think you have assault what is
it with stupid-ass people in movies
I'm the new horseman seems like this is
something Dylan could have easily
informed the group about well before she
was introduced but when I keep your
secret magic team in the loop right we
have been rehearsing for months for
something we don't even know what it is
well why did you do that that's a long
time to trust a magic FBI guys word
right I mean without results I'm not
going anywhere
but I'm mm I'm taking care of myself it
appears that Jesse Eisenberg didn't
really quit ass Lex Luthor when he got
on the set of this movie you want to
know what all this has been leading to
Octus hosting the launch of the next-gen
cell phone once these phones at the
streets they'll siphon their users
information to the black market also
really they've been biding their time
waiting for an evil cellphone maker to
release a phone
why not magic The Forgotten terrorists
our mission is to hijack the show
Brussels over guys how do you rehearse
for hijacking a cell phone launch a year
in advance without knowing that's what
it's going to be until just before the
show and why was that such privileged
information they couldn't inform their
trusted members that's what they were
training for this is what we've been
waiting for now it's time to get the
world
since when do the world's best magicians
blindly sign up to be basically MacGyver
going after wrongdoers and corporate
Stooges also why are they all shining
their flashlights on these blueprints in
the shot that's no flashlight activated
blueprints or an actual thing
man that journalist have got to be
pissed that blockers got billing above
them also bloggers let's see just
signature for Elise this works this
actually fucking works
I should be a magician because I'm great
with people and have frequently talked
strangers into signing iPads impossible
Bell toss guy just came flies you know
notorious horseman Daniel Atlas who's
been in all the news over the past year
anybody recognize I guess not that's
your Evans mental facility Marc D stooge
these guys would hold this guy way
without checking with the powers that be
first is an integral part of this
year-long plan being put into motion
right now when I was a cool scientist
but the four horsemen relying on
strangers to abide by random safety
science that's a battle and wait isn't
this just a live feed why is it
recording and if it's recording wouldn't
someone see the tape where Woody
Harrelson's face is in the shot he's
obviously hypnotized this guy ladies and
gentlemen the horsemen aren't they
wanted criminals doesn't Twitter betray
their location in a matter of seconds
shouldn't they get arrested before they
finished the introductions this guy here
in the crowd is yelling weird the
redhead horsemen go ah so I was right
about the instant police response but
wrong and thinking the horsemen couldn't
foil the FBI with the old lock the doors
routine we got an anonymous phone call
an hour ago confirms everything I've
been telling her but we're not going to
arrest you right now or anything because
that would be silly Max Headroom years
as a thing and because this guy already
suspected Rhoades he fucking slams him
and tries to cuff him what are they
really rehearsing during that whole year
that didn't really involve magic they
made the octa guy what he was doing in
front of a crowd but then they all came
out and started telling the crowd in
more detail how this guy was screwing
them and what were they going to do
afterward they are running for their
lives but this asshole took the time to
change out of his green security guard
outfit how is this possible
it's not though the movie will go on
later to try and use some hypnosis
bullshit which is just as bolted as any
other explanations this movie offers
also these guys were apparently
introduced to a world where real magic
exists and one of their members is now
asking how it's possible also of course
they ended up in China because Chinese
audiences won't accept anything that has
no China in it and they censor the word
pandering what the actual movie this is
my twin brother chase what the actual
movie also character has a twin brother
or any kind of sibling that they never
mentioned before cliche the greatest
magicians in the world are the object of
someone else's magic trick it's not
poetic I don't really know it's stupid
this is some Eddie Murphy movie hey I
will sit no to the sequel that's okay
we'll just double would you screen
time will give him a twin brilliant I'm
pretty sure he's still driving an FBI
issued car I'm also pretty sure that
they'd be able to track that and his
cell phone but this movie is too busy
surprising you to care about petty
details like logic and common sense
wham-o close ammo delivery guy came to
your door Merritt who is in hiding
apparently but lives in a regular house
apartment decides that checking the
peephole is for suckers son opens the
door for any asshole who drinks how did
you know how to find him is this movie
really trying to tell us that these guys
are hiding out so well that nobody could
possibly find them they don't wear
disguises and they live in apartments
where they could be seen daily it's not
like they're in a bunker and I don't
know what I'd to lean while I marvel at
how much the city shots remind me of The
Fast and Furious movies
I'm also marvel at how this movie is
actually somehow more both than the Fast
& Furious movies I just want to be end
and I am 100% off the grid you were not
off the grid dick you might be living
under an assumed name but as long as
you're in a penthouse apartment with
electricity this is the very definition
of on the grid dick I'd like that we had
a dream movie goes for the super
discount gates jobs angle because this
movie believes it's original and clever
right down to the casting of King Harry
Potter as the villain it can unencrypt
and the same track the defense firewall
suits the kansai or the box from
sneakers we're calling your bluff
actually we'll do it because I speak for
everyone in this group here and there
will be no argument for some reason
sending the idea that this wanted
criminal can still visit prisoners at a
federal penitentiary and that this guard
hasn't heard the news yet about this
super famous FBI agent having turned out
to be a criminal even if he is using
Cowan's FBI credentials what else ladies
and gentlemen in prison
this article repeats itself five times
and pretty much all the other articles
around it repeat all the same paragraphs
from this one making it the worst case
of plagiarism and repetition in media
history and I didn't get to finish my
lobster this motherfucker has lobster
dinners a computer a flat-screen of
cooking a spresso machine a lazy boy and
all the privacy in the world
this isn't prison this is my idea in
heaven man hi how are ya Daniel believes
that in Macau you can just go and speak
English to anybody and they'll know
what's up we're going through a very
sensitive metal detector so plastic
nothing metal it is absolutely
incredible how unlikable Daniel atlas is
in this movie and he's supposed to be
our main protagonist what did she say
she says just because you are talking
sorry and moving your hands doesn't mean
she can subtly on the stain wish this
guy would be amazing at cinema since but
what a terrible scene this is when the
old lady asked why he needs something in
plastic
rather than getting the younger guy to
translate for him he tries to talk to
her in this demeaning manner all set up
for a joke but then after he scolded for
speaking that way he doesn't even bother
trying to get this guy to translate for
it and simply moves on as if it's a lost
cause
so that's how we've been contacting the
I you've been doing it on your own what
was the process by which Atlas figured
out how to talk to the AI and later we
find out he's been talking to Daniel
Radcliffe the whole time who's
pretending to be the I so how did that
happen is it weird to have more hair in
your nose than on your head
movie thinks the split screen this
hilarious simply by existing and
declines to include any dialogue or
action year that is worth watching this
is literally watch would you play off
what he seen for the sake of hey so how
did the convicted felon who's out of
prison on a one day something something
and the disgraced FBI agent the entire
agency is looking for managed to charter
a private jet this is the thing that the
check is very thin luckily it's similar
and weight and size to a playing card
luckily the South African gangsters
security detail somehow gets completely
flummoxed by a dragon costume separating
them from their client and don't seem to
be in any hurry to make sure he isn't in
any danger right now
well noting its predecessor and movie
takes hypnosis all the way to the
goddamn moon I got your email dr.
McLucas you had a query about our
ability to maintain quantum coherence at
room temperature somehow even though
they knew everything about this South
African gangster they did not do enough
research to know who was who in his
entourage leading to these comic hijinks
that are so hilarious
[Applause]
are you kidding me you knew you'd have
to walk through a metal detector and the
chip was metal but you went through with
the plan without knowing how you were
gonna beat that 820 million cubic miles
of dizzy synaptic residents two hours
and nine minutes of absolute garbage
babble bulls now you see me to ghost
Protocol
okay so they replace the microchip with
a comb or whatever the fuck isn't this
thing a microchip meaning taking out of
the computer will cause it computer not
to work any more alarms going off
warnings about a missing microchip it's
a good thing no one is looking this
direction and that there are no cameras
in this super important high security
room I mean right
also Penn & Teller watch the scene and
promptly vomited and no they were not
fooled I don't care how good you aren't
throwing cards there's no way you
practice this throw under these kinds of
conditions to make it perfect go fuck
yourself I know it's supposed to be fun
and everything but it looks piggish so
I'm actively rooting for them to get
caught
guard can every single one of these
assholes has to perform sleight of hand
with this card that has the microchip on
it but why couldn't Jack just keep the
card after he got searched
why did he throw it to Daniel so he'd
have to do all the same only to pass it
on to Loula who also
to do the same we are now supposed to
believe that merit got good at this in
that montage we saw earlier that nobody
saw this and why did they get merit to
do this why didn't they just make it so
that merits wallet got confiscated at
the beginning and make it Dave Franco's
job to throw the car also this plan
entirely relies on a protocol where the
guards pass a confiscated wallet through
a metal detector so that the horsemen
can do this simultaneous card throwing
trick to beat the system oh wow you
speak Mandarin we're gonna need to put
them watching Dao well I can eat young
everybody speaks Mandarin because magic
the oldest magic shop in the world in
Macau has a false back that opens into
what I can only describe as a ninja
turtles rumor requirement
he's was the fathers we find out later
that these shop owners are part of the I
so it makes sense they know who Shrike
is but Shrike doesn't know that and he
did reveal his identity unless they
overheard Thaddeus and him all the way
across the magic shop some bullsh even
for this movie but whatever I'm actually
writing these sins with my left hand on
my right hand is skimming through the TV
Guide looking for MasterChef Canada
reruns some pus on the scholarship and
I'm abric of you I'm assuming it was
actually not you who walked into Newberg
federal prison these assholes are just
now finding this out how do you think we
were able to find him your phone I asked
to see the face behind all of this will
you actually put your phone on was a by
wave siphon pad what an absolute bat
crazy plan luckily worked in Mabry's
favor so he could download everyone's
personal information this is obvious
subterfuge that Mabry will fall forward
we give Marvel movies aren't time for
overcutting fight scenes but Jesus this
movie took the same class but OD don't
extra credit it's like 10 of you know
decent tricks movie is going to try to
make me believe that Dylan who all now
is a great magician somehow winning
because he's able to do magic tricks in
an uncontrolled environment stuff like
this for example in this movie magic
equals iron monkey villain levels of
fabric control that's Lionel Shrike safe
which any self-respecting magician would
recognize on sight from a hundred yards
away done movie thinks it's gonna
surprise me with some sort of Michael
Caine reveal that I guessed as soon as I
saw Daniel Radcliffe in this movie
ultimately this entire sequel is a
revenge plot from the last movies
outcome which is the creative equivalent
of a shark instead of just killing the
guy they decide that his death needs to
be poetic in some way to put him in a
safe that is for magicians and leave it
to chance and of course the bad guys
toss a magician into a magician safe and
didn't bother to take his belongings his
day
don't make themselves now you will find
yourself in a very similar position to
mr. Rhodes yeah but why what did
Thaddeus do to you in the last movie
that makes you angry at him also if you
haven't guessed Morgan Freeman there's
actually a good guy in this movie you've
never seen a movie
hoist my neck smacking at all so this is
a clear issue with the I in this movie
so secretive they won't even let you
know who's working with you and what you
need to do to succeed because Atlas
needed to be here to pull Dylan out of
the water but only knew to be here
because the bad guys were loading his
dad's death safe into the back of a
truck and followed it but what if they
didn't see that feeling come on buddy
breathe he says this despite none of
them attempting CPR he just thinks this
guy's gonna start breathing on his own
he may be a world-class magician but his
ass did not pay attention in health
class sake I didn't bother to check
between the time we stole in and out
even though I can apparently tell it's
fake nasaan sight and I was the one that
took its fake ass out of the bad guys
computer you were chosen all of you it's
magic movie just inception itself so
lose it god damn it this movie in it's
characters did not need a who's in I'm
an one by one scene it has one but it he
doesn't need it if he's thinking YouTube
live streaming reaches the entire
world's population he's super duper
mistake how do we stay ahead of them we
need to get to London by midnight
wait what how the I mean where did you
pull that I mean movie makes it seem
like everyone in the world would just
stand up in delight at the mere sight of
Jack Wilder
when at least three of these people
would likely call the cops now here is
Loula just join the horsemen in this
movie and up until this point has had
only one public appearance that failed
miserably yet everyone regards her leg
she's isla Fisher from that last movie
already why are there so many people
standing out in a downpour right outside
wherever that this is I know he's about
to magic it but 95% of these people are
not actually here in a downpour in real
life
freeze that ensue min zoom and enhance
cliche he's dead we watched him drown
out actually no face you didn't you did
the same thing every Bond villain ever
does and assume he drowned before
verifying it not make it naked go up
this is like a really bad Crystal Pepsi
commercial that was an act of me you're
wearing a microphone but where the fuck
are the speakers and why doesn't your
voice sound even a little bit amplified
that was an act of B
and of strobe lights and rain machines
obviously this trick needed rain
machines to work but how come everybody
in the area had umbrellas on them
already yeah I know it's London and it
rains all the time but surely the
forecast showed a clear night and there
would have been less umbrellas than
usual actually impossible god damn it
also impossible this movie is just curry
on top of curry but because it has
actors you like you end up thinking this
horse is entertaining when it really is
just whore
this magician dude goes full boring for
a few minutes because of course it does
because motorcycles always explode on
impact we later find out this whole
thing is a setup by the horsemen to get
caught by tesslar and is met now
normally we've mentioned the prestige
level of commitment these guys are
bringing to the set up but that would
actually be likely in this case only the
acting here is way above and beyond to
the point that the actors don't even
appear to know that their characters are
in on it
also note that Tesla's already tried
throwing Dylan into a safe and dropping
it into the river so he should have a
short fuse and just kill these guys
right now and search them for the chip
later nope
instead he does everything according to
the Horseman's plant surreal how does
the microchip reel didn't they have a
fake one how did they make this past the
test
this is never explained at all we find
out later that the whole showcase for
the microchip was staged but that
doesn't explain how they thought the
microchip was fake and now it's real the
champagne tastes weird so of course he
peels off the label immediately right
the tennis stroke of midnight New Year's
Eve is that microphone still working so
they were broadcasting this around the
world but Tressler and Mabry and all the
people who work for them weren't
watching did the horsemen accomplish
that or know where that would happen
here's the most unbelievable thing in
the movie by far somehow Jack managed to
be here hypnotizing Merritt's brother
also being back at the other place
playing fine the lady game with the
adoring public these man destroyed
people's lives and that's when most
people would probably start heading for
the exits it's when the magic show gets
preachy that they lose the audience
awesome
but you horsemen are all still super one
at criminals though right this doesn't
change that does it uh even this so
unformed it might as well be a zygote
romance story gets wrapped up nicely
huzzah and by huzzah I mean give me a
goddamn break already ten minutes this
new FBI director person has absolutely
no real connection to do and whatsoever
but because he's giving her a flash
drive full of alleged info on Pressler
and mabry she's okay with this guy
getting a head start for some reason
even though he's broken plenty of laws
now you're playing the long game Hulk
just pulled a Batman it keeps going and
going and going and going and yes your
father and I were partners which in this
incredible world of the Internet
no one ever figured out even his son who
had access to the FBI and lived in this
world of magic didn't know somehow this
is harder to believe than any magic
trick that occurs in these movies why
don't you ever say anything to me I
don't know yeah the usual I did it to
protect you
I had guilt shame whatever you want to
call it never once is this excuse made
since ever give it a name shame guilt
regret he's talking about that tie he's
wearing right now right hey guys
you might want to come take a look at
this you might want to come take a look
at this cliche I put you in jail man why
didn't you say something then probably
because his prison cell was better than
my entire house also Thaddeus will now
explain that he didn't want to say
anything because he wanted Dylan to do
this magic but the right motivation he
spent 18 months in prison as an old man
because he didn't want to explain
anything plus it ties up everything so
neatly you'll forget about this being a
major flaw in the film Walter and
Tressler you were they in on it too oh
we knew Walter was in hiding the Optus
show was a setup to expose him to the
public that explains nothing this is
first off a confusing question we're the
people we exposed in on the overall plan
I mean what second off Thaddeus gives
pretty much a nothing answer to the
question in fact pretty much nothing of
this plan is explained at all if they
knew all this then they might be worse
invaders of privacy than Mabry was
planning to be also remember this plan
requires them to go to China and one
Horseman who apparently speaks for all
the other unwilling horsemen to do
whatever may be said get the idea to go
to a magic shop that just happens to
have the eye people there along with all
the other lucky happens dances that
occurred and what is overall a poorly
conceived plant now I know why you look
so familiar
you'll the horsemen on you I know this
guy was in the movie earlier and that
this should be some kind of trouble
worthy call back whammy problem is this
movie is so I can't remember where I saw
this dude also yes it is the guy who was
showing them the microchip earlier but
wouldn't it have been nice to know he
was helping them couldn't have made
things a little easier seeing is
believing
but is it true movie rips off the ending
Morgan Freeman narration bit from War of
the Worlds Kinshasa and Million Dollar
Baby Bruce Almighty 7 march of the
Penguins and the studio said who should
we get to direct this piece of maybe the
guy who did one of those step up movies
someone said maybe the person who did
just
Bieber Never Say Never said another Jim
in the Holograms no no we need the guy
who did GI Joe retaliation do you Frank
someone yell suddenly the executives
were at one another's necks punches were
thrown and guns were drawn until Timmy
the intern looked up from his computer
and said guys guys we can get all the
people who did those movies to direct
this movie because it's all the same
person
but everyone was too dead to hear
[Music]
yeah it is for most people spend their
lives in the dark trying to hide from me
there's a harsh truth to face no way I'm
gonna make it on the outside faith
remember remember the 5th of November
you know you really don't need a
forensics team to get to the bottom of
this if you guys were the inventors of
Facebook you'd have invented Facebook
and I'm yeah no no what am I
I once told you about a sailor who
described drowning to me because he said
it was like going home of a sly he said
it was agony